- "Kinda surprised no one is
talking about Sam and Grizz."
- "Sazz, Gram?
"I love this ship from
all my heart, for real."
- Hey, I'm Kathryn Newton.
- Alex.
- Hi, I'm Gideon.
- Jacques.
- I'm Natasha.
- And we're gonna read some fan reactions.
(upbeat music)
- Moving on. (laughing)
"Netflix's 'The Society,'
"or Rich Kids 'Game of Thrones' Cosplay."
(Kathryn laughing)
- Wait, who's Khaleesi?
Allie?
- Yeah.
- That makes me Drogo.
- Next one.
- No!
Hold on!
- "Alex Fitzalan as Harry,
that's the tweet!"
- "That's it."
"That's the tweet."
- "That's it,
that's the tweet." (laughing)
- "I have an unhealthy crush
on Grizz from 'The Society.'
"Someone please tell Jack
Mulhern to get social media,
"so I can look at his face."
He does have a really nice face, and...
- "Was fully expecting this new
Netflix show, 'The Society,'
"to be a sci-take on
'Pretty Little Liars.'
"Instead, it's like millennials
"robustly testing out the theories
"of post-apocalyptic governance.
"Waht? Huge mood."
- That's just intelligent.
Thank you, husnara.
- Wow.
- Uh, "me, cause I just finished
'The Society' on Netflix
"and that ending fucked me up."
- But it's supposed to fuck your shit up.
- It really is.
- It's supposed to do that.
That's okay.
- "My two favorite genres.
"I'm calling it now;
"Kathryn Newton will be the
only one to survive this.
"She picked up some hunting
skills on 'Supernatural.'"
- Claire on "Supernatural,"
like she knows how to use a gun.
And then when we shot the
execution scene, they were like,
"Kathryn, you look too professional.
"You need to tone it down."
- "Cassandra made a
group of 250 plus teens
"living by themselves
into a functional town
"with a democracy. Wow."
- That's impressive.
- Yeah, she a real mensch. She a good one.
She a real one.
- I love Cassandra.
I don't know why there's
hate on Cassandra.
- "Why is no one talking
about the bus driver?"
- My thoughts, exactly.
He was creepy!
- Becca's flipping
through the phone, right?
Like he's right there in those photos.
- There's more than one bus driver, guys.
Where did they go?
(Jacques laughing)
- "The dog can travel between dimensions."
- I like this already.
- This is cool.
- "Women be doing
politics and men be like,
"'What if we, like...'"
- "'Didn't... take stuff?'"
- "'Take stuff.'"
(laughing)
- It's so funny!
'Cause that's accurate!
- "I love it, and Grizz
and Sam deserve the world.
"The fact that Grizz wanted
to learn sign language
"to be able to talk to him properly,
"he really cares about him."
- "I can't wait for them
to live on their farm
"together forever and get married!"
(clapping) Me too!
I think my baby has two dads.
- It's got a picture of a cat.
- A crying kitty!
- I had a cat for 13
years and he never cried.
- What are you talking about
That cat was watching the show.
- Right, but I don't think they
physically have tear ducts.
(laughing)
- "Nobody. Not a single soul.
"Harry: We're playing fugitive."
- "I have a bit of a theory.
"What if, during the school trip,
"the buses got into some
sort of freak accident
"and they all died?"
- What are we, in purgatory or something?
So we live out our lives,
and then die again,
and then really die?
- We're the dimensional fractal.
(mimicking an exploding sound)
- Thanks for all the tweets and memes.
I mean, I love looking
at them, so thank you.
- Thank you.
(laughing)
Thank you, guys.
(bubbly music)